you feel like you're violating people's
privacy you feel like you're adequately
portrayed as a because I want to wonder
about the person who actually created
this thing yeah I mean you know a lot of
stuff happened but along the way I think
you know there were real learning points
and turning points along the way in
terms of in terms of building things you
know it really went from this position
very early on where we were just in this
college dorm area - we moved out to
California it was a few friends and me
and you know just kind of had this
project field for a while and there's
this real turning point when we complete
start trying to buy the company for a
huge amount of money and you know I tell
you kind of get my friends together and
we had to decide what was it that we
really cared about and what was it that
we wanted to do and you know we decided
not to take those offers and right you
know to me a lot of that decision was
that what we wanted to do and what we
wanted to spend you know a big part of
our lives doing which is just continuing
to push and and and kind of build
products that help people share
information build products that help
people stay connected and that's really
what we're spending our time doing and
you know I think there's just been a lot
of a lot of space between that early
stuff and where we are now if I could if
I knew what I knew now then then I hope
I wouldn't have made those mistakes but
I can't go back and change the past I
can only do what we think is the right
thing going forward so before we move up
this privacy thing and never take off I
know there's a group of women in the
audience that wish you would
can you explain what this instant
personalization thing was that you did
and why you did it
what was the what's the value of it to
users all right yeah this is a great
moment in internet history what we into
the mic sorry Beth it yeah yeah yeah no
it's a hoodie we it's um it's a company
hoodie we print our mission on the
inside what oh really
the inside of the hoodie everybody take
a lot what is it
making the making the world more open
and connected oh my god it's like school
oh look at that
making the world open and connected
stream graph platform and this weird
symbol in the middle that is probably
for the Illuminati Oh mm oh it's mm oh
no